graph a line that has a slope that is
negative and greater than the slope of
the blue line so let's think for a
second about what slope means so if you
use the word slope in your everyday life
you're really talking about how inclined
something is like a ski slope so for
example this orange line isn't inclined
at all it's flat so this one actually
has a slope of 0 another way of thinking
about it is as x increases what is
happening to Y and you see here that Y
isn't changing at all so this orange
line right now has a slope of 0 if the
orange line looked like this it now has
a positive slope notice when X is
negative your Y value or say when X is
negative 5 your Y value is here and then
when X is positive 5 your Y value has
increased as x increases Y is increasing
so this has a positive slope this has an
even more positive slope and even more
positive slope this has an even more
positive slope as X is increasing the Y
values increasing really fast this line
is going up really fast as we move
towards the right so it's a very
positive slope this is less positive
less positive this is a 0 this is a 0
slope and then this is a negative slope
notice as X is increasing the line is
going down your Y value is decreasing
when X is when X is negative 5 your Y is
7 while when X is 5 your Y is 5 so X has
increased but Y has gone down so this is
a negative slope so they say graph a
line that has a slope that is negative
and greater than the slope of the blue
line so the blue line also has a
negative slope as X is increasing your
blue line is going down it went over
here when X has negative values your Y
value is quite high and here when X has
positive values your Y value has gone
all the way down so this has a negative
slope but we want to have a slope
greater than this one so we still want
to have a they say graph a line that has
a slope that is negative so my orange
line currently has a negative slope and
greater than the slope of the blue line
so it has a negative slope but it is
less negative than the
blue line right over here if I wanted to
be more negative than the blue line I'd
have to do something like that but I
want to be negative and like but less
negative than the blue line so that
would be like that if we wanted a zero
slope once again something like this if
we wanted a positive slope something
like this so once again negative slope
less negative then the blue line check
our answer